this is a like a miracle
they've rehearsed this for eight years they
started shooting this an extraction one
[Music] citizens of the reject Nation we're
gonna watch extraction two today joined by
koi genre Coy how you feeling I love extraction
one so much and I've been waiting for this
for so many years too haven't even seen the
trailers for it I haven't either but I hear
there's a really long Wonder in this ladies
and gentlemen extract that like button do
it right now and as always full length and
watch along where you sync up with your own
copy of extraction 2 available for super sexy
Rejects at our patreon page cover so much
stuff exclusively over there with reaction
highlights and watch along concluded cool
you excited to jump into the Sam Hargreaves
one of my favorite new directors and Chris
Hemsworth is Chris Hemsworth so I am so ready
okay [Music] somehow it being Chris Hemsworth
makes me think he could actually survive that
just because oh yeah he's not Jeremy Renner
come on
about
I take uh yearly trips to Dubai oh yeah on
my first class plane oh just to check in just
checking weekend trip
I like that extraction it's the French film
[Music]
I actually like that we're getting this we
could have just John Wicked it yeah no I like
that he's a human let him be he had to recover
and work his way through there through resilience
looks genuinely painful thanks Nick for keeping
me around really excited about this next chapter
of my life
now that's pretty difficult to let someone
you care about die oh he knows the feeling
would you afford your way back you just have
to find out why to kill more people
this is like Shaw it's a fast and furious
films guys family
oh homie
[Music] oh he's the Reaper
my man looking good look at this what's with
the shirt those are bed or something you like
it no [Laughter]
what about my dog oh we ate her too I'm joking
she's in the house so what am I supposed to
do now eat your dog
[Music]
I like how these movies do these Action Hero
tropes like this could have been the start
of the first movie you know those like 80s
action movies where they're like I'm retired
I've gone through it and I'm recovering you
don't even know why
ha ha hahaha
[Music]
must be the absolute worst losing your kid
cannot imagine I just registered that he's
staying at a cabin in the woods oh it's all
come full circle Hemsworth
[Music] it's gonna become fat Thor I just
love that he loves chicken it's like what
a great character thing foreign
[Music]
the fact that they locked up his whole family
for him is like such a villainy yeah being
buried with someone
distraction three 60 year old Hemsworth takes
on this kid yeah yeah this is beautiful amazing
did not know foreign I'm so happy
friend who's offered you a job I don't have
any friends yeah well this particular individual
seems to think you're the only one that can
do it yes I'm not so convinced can you even
put a trigger like that
and that's why you haven't got any would you
go back and tell her I've sent you I'm not
interested what if it was your ex-wife was
it or is it just a hypothetical I mean is
it just asking just curious but her sister
is she's currently in a Georgian prism of
her two kids her husband's locked her in there
can you imagine that call themselves The nagazi
if it wasn't for the Americans to have it
to be free love movies like this I'd want
to get in there nice and quiet keep my head
down Ken you can rest assured that his brother's
going to want to throw everything at you and
I'm talking about the home the gazi Army oh
this would be good I was so excited this should
be good job starts in six weeks we take our
cut if all goes well you don't get caught
or shot in the face I'll meet you on the other
side and give her a kiss I hope he gets action
scenes I can only see him as Luther when he
has a popped collar like I just solved with
the recruit Thor why did they come to you
haven't you heard Nick I'm a bit of a legend
now I tell you what the job is and when and
how you do it you also told me to find the
reason I fought my way back let's find out
specific children rescue missions it's what
I do yeah I love an implausible plot Underdog
evil villainy I like it's all the things I
want
training montage yeah Rocky 4 style what's
happening oh there he is
the show Limitless on Disney Plus
thank you well that arm cast was really holding
him back really was that goes this is almost
last two hours doesn't need six weeks
we should be able to tell when we're our winner
right oh there's no way we won't I assume
it's gonna be a prison Runner okay because
I think they're gonna find him and then the
whole way out one
I'm ready koi it's happening I'm ready ready
for him to kill a bunch of prisoners we just
learned they were bad he did some push-ups
cut up some logs threw an ax he's ready to
go muscle memory this Rock's over there now
I'm ready
badass he is so badass he is so cool yeah
he's so badass
uh-oh where does his son's loyalties lie
oh smart mom
yikes
sorry kid [Music] rise from the dead
I think we're in the water is this it I think
so I feel it
I think so you're right let's go water our
water sense was tingling that was early it's
early it's an early water dammit
hitting cut I saw it unprofessional
dumbass
[Music] nice
that sound design
so exciting
on it did I just kill everyone at this point
[Music]
foreign good boy
kind of worried the mom's gonna die yeah she's
pretty great and that worries me yeah
that's part of a video game oh yeah
no oh
it'll happen oh
[Applause] ouch gosh I feel so painful
ah
yes yes I hate this split thingy it's really
painful it's no growth oh not a fan not a
fan we what happened down there trouble where's
my father come on come on he's fine he's waiting
for you outside he's waiting free yeah
[Music] how they did that lift so smooth
it's cool how we're like going around to different
players yeah holy [__] holy [__] we're
doing a full-on prison right this is crazy
Charlie that isn't through the common yard
s there must be another way stay close to
me right how about nobody's side everyone
die
all right dude she's the the greatest video
game partner truly
[__]
just starts Ryan
God damn what impressive ass choreography
two-person video game fight
whoa oh God
he's awesome
oh [Music] laughs
beautiful oh it's so impressive this is still
the same shot
ouch
yeah yeah oh this is so impressive
God damn it [Laughter]
whoa how did they transition into this shot
cause it's locked on his stomach what they
like how did they want to do that what did
I walk on [Music]
how did they do that this doesn't make any
sense
oh my God we've added fire he's on fire now
the star test fire he's here's enough flaming
fist how do you choreograph fire in a water
he's gone
[Music] oh
[Music] dude I have so much adrenaline that
was awesome yeah you guys are doing great
the way they transition these locked off shots
is like blowing my mind it is so it's not
like what how do you leave it
I love the tension of this kid that's gonna
betray us I know [Music]
I love it just like a video game we're in
the car now how got it can't get rid of these
guys already on it I mean how did they just
do that these these like hidden cuts are phenomenal
because I can't see them damn it I've seen
maybe two yeah
oh my God I love it I'm so happy right now
I've got goosebumps they keep going down and
coming back up back up here soldiers these
men are killers yeah so am I
there we go this guy should have directed
The Uncharted movie oh man
damn
this is nuts
it doesn't even look like drones like it's
like destroying camera work how did we just
do that shot
ah
the glass can only hold for so long
there's such great CGI in this if the old
school like Fincher thing going through Windows
doing it so well yeah yeah it blends perfectly
ah so badass
[Music] oh the girls hurt yeah
it's it's your new family Tyler they found
him now it's a foot chase we've got so much
yeah we've gone through so many different
kinds of actions he was punching people with
fire not five minutes ago [Music]
get these extras out of here the infusion
of extras makes it so much more re-depth yeah
adding in the human element oh there's so
much foreground play to add tension
now we're going on a train really every type
of automobile is this the rest of the movie
is a water this is like a miracle
they rehearse this for eight years they started
shooting this an extraction one
we've added helicopters Greg I'll have a shot
at the helicopters just in case I gotta go
oh my God oh my God yes oh my God he's going
Stallone first Blood get it oh my God yes
what is this video game Sam Hargrave direct
everything
oh my God
oh what was that guy doing he was a good guy
what was he doing I think he I think he got
hit from down the way okay
oh my God yeah
oh lady I forgot how hot you were she is awesome
oh man close combat knife gunfights
oh
God her
reaction to the pain feels so real it's so
much coming the location that we're going
like 80 in a tiny room
this choreography is so inspiring yeah whoever
shot this like the physical DP it's like a
video game cutscene
Legend
oh
great great
little boy don't trust him you're good better
than him
what are you gonna do so you gotta jump is
he gonna jump
what a badass
yes secure the family we've got no price oh
no it snaps speed on a train somehow this
is gonna segue into a Kaiju fight
I figured foreign
oh it's over it ended on a train roll like
it's a good way to end it oh damn how long
was that like 85 minutes I'm so tired that
was so long but it it's stayed engaging throughout
they had so much variety every type of action
a slow burn start to like have a little character
moment man that was a whole movie's worth
of action yeah let's turn it off that's good
thanks we don't know who this other brother's
gonna do he's got nothing proof there's no
Warner coming in with him no deal with them
Oscar Isaac the one that designs ex machina
yeah oh I love this guy it's one of these
87 North guys yeah yeah yeah they're talking
about she said
it was an extraction two that scar is so cool
like the idea that his face like
that's gonna go that is one of the might be
the greatest action scene sequence of the
year it was incredible
bye guy you got a new dad right there and
he's very he's very strong kick your biological
dad's ass kill them did you kill him did you
kill him just lie you have no attachment to
this kid I helped he was gonna kill your mother
okay
now he's gotta watch his back like that's
and should have said nope I would have just
lied just like maybe he's a bad liar like
no one into your dad he was dead when I found
him I tried to get him out yeah [Music]
and she wonders oh damn that's hell
it's down in 45 minutes you have to break
the cycle little boy this is
need anything my dad I'm hungry oh don't do
it don't give him a fork don't give him the
phone knife
since when do you speak Jordan
he was married to my sister that's where the
ex-wife thing came in yeah I was gonna tell
you [Laughter]
Tyler your nephew's a punk don't trust him
not really nephew anymore step nephew half
nephew myself you're almost free I'm gonna
get you guys someplace safe okay I promise
this better lead to a great action scene Ross
I'm just gonna stay mad at you I hate this
kid
son of a [__]
come on little man break the cycle listen
I don't know what's your sister must think
of me and there's nothing I can do to fix
that I just want you to know that it's the
most awful thing a parent can endure watching
a child die or surpass you financially and
not help you out
oh I'm still like reeling can you imagine
they put this in the theaters Netflix Netflix
killing me people just be melted into the
receipts 40x just punching your spine I wouldn't
have said no to this it was important to you
it is trying to get back in with his wife
this is the way it's the long game gotta start
a small Cold War get her back
alone I mean this movie is so cool looking
it's only supposed to stay with his father
a good father wouldn't make him yeah well
it's my father didn't leave us does he know
who Tyler really is it seems like it seems
like a very pointed Jab
one little hoist Chris
see if a kid lose a kid still safe trying
to try to Pat him on the back Pat him a little
too hard fell over here
she died she stayed with your father for years
to keep you safe I'm not gonna lie to you
mine shit's gonna get harder from here but
you're gonna have to take care of her she's
gonna need you so you can be there for her
like she was for you I'll let your father's
lives consume you father's lives are gonna
come knocking any second now it's on you mate
tell him tell Tyler what you did give him
a head start I'm sorry
no he's coming oh
we gotta move I found this because of your
son your son screwed up he covered up oh no
she knows she knows
oh no
now he has to know
how do they know what floor I'm guessing they
tracked the phone
helicopters like let's get out of here
he has known to shoot at helicopters as much
jokes as we make I actually I do get where
the little boys oh sure he grew up in it yeah
man yeah most people are complaining about
us have not made it to the point where we
reveal that we understand excuse us we get
it as well yeah but we do get it
Nick stain radio contact okay but my understanding
for the kid has the limit yeah there's a line
he just got shot at yeah
yeah damn look at this big guy
whoa whoa
damn
just an ankle he's going to the back alley
come back here come back to your mother your
mother did all of this to protect you come
back I mean you made this far kid might as
well go with your uncle be evil [Music] oh
my God
did they just kill her I think they might
have
how did she survive that
oh
looks like it'd be so fun to train for this
movie they must have been insane learning
all these movements
whoa oh damn
everyone earlier to engage
damn he barely even took a second aim he is
very good at the missile launcher oh
he aimed the helicopter or Chris Hemsworth
man even the bad guys are so well trained
the beautiful sets to destroy didn't even
flinch them sugar quit there's nothing to
be sorry about getting you out of here okay
I'm gonna get you back to your sister just
make sure she hears about this I really miss
her let her know tell her very Vivid details
thousands of people died for us to get back
together lots of police
[Music] how did he rig that that was cool
I got this go I I keep getting where she's
gonna die it's her she said I got this you
don't say I got this
[Music] weights
ouch oh oh
nice there we go there we go oh [Music] Jeff
's coming of a nice shot they killed buff
Perry nimrov yeah
treadmill
oh
mind blowing he's gonna slide past her oh
he's shooting just blow himself down oh yes
that was genius oh we're going to enjoy killing
you yeah get in line oh
yeah I must really care for this woman no
no it feels to lose someone in love
whoa
trust me should I not
oh [__] oh the old dumbbell toss right
back into the gym
kettlebell swing I wouldn't even be like do
you trust me I would just throw her
she had an ax on him
oh the big guys we gotta put them like a 500
bullets the big guys oh or just one headshot
gotta got him first
wow this is a terrifying action scene
foreign
[Music]
uh his way Dad um way dead yeah okay stay
with me buddy I've got you I got you yeah
oh I
liked him yeah
he must have the biggest headache right now
pain pain
everyone is in so much pain Robbie had pain
right now I said nothing worse than a headache
except a hole in the hand man I don't know
man that is pretty rough that I had to slow
you down even more she's like really is
oh no way
not even say hi I was that was very awkward
do you have any idea what he's done it doesn't
get through the details he killed a man with
a leg press machine to keep her alive if that
doesn't win you back
that's not
you're gonna push him
oh
this is Dumbo Mulan Eddie Murphy foreign
come on man you gotta be smarter than that
he's been that his whole life you should have
seen that even I saw this coming I've known
you guys for 20 minutes I mean come on lifetime
of this oh the imagery though
maybe he just had enough oh even now he could
deliver cold and cool lines yeah right yeah
what is no he's betrayed you [Laughter]
it's a traitor sorry McDonald's gotta mess
you up got a lot of people killed him
should have been there for years I don't want
to hear it but you want to hear about the
moving train and the helicopter I love this
because it's the ultimate Betrayal on both
parties like like what he did is Unthinkable
but we're also like he just did a lot like
it's such a good conflict
I didn't
it's a great line it's a very real one yeah
exactly it's a summation yeah
why don't you tell me where you are and we
can finish what we started I want to negotiate
I'm not coming to negotiate what did he say
I'm not coming to negotiate it's a straight
up Stallone Arnold movie from the 80s so and
it 100 is that I felt the same way just with
better special effects it's just like water
but with modern day sensibilities is how they
do it I love it with like a John Wick sensibility
and stuff like yeah with the 87 North team
and everything like yeah man it's cool but
like both of these movies are exceptional
action movies stay with her get them out open
the door she's got revenge too she has revenge
too you could have let her revenge [Music]
wow that was a lot louder than I expect very
intense with a little like a little sniper
little flare gun explosion [Music]
that was so dope
oh
damn this is so cool
[Music] oh no where was he shot
oh gut shot no no we need an extraction three
don't give us another fake out death oh it's
gonna end in a church symbolism God fathers
Sons original sin guilt architecture
okay [Laughter]
come
Jesus sometimes there's a great sacrifice
in an acting God's will kid pull the trigger
consume yourself in a lifetime of guilt he
already lives that way
oh he's gonna make up children
what is it
smooth
ie
yes well you can exact retribution for your
brother but it will be at the cost of his
life right now it's on the girl how did he
know they were brother and sister racist that
racism comes in handy sometimes
laughs [Music] no no no
oh no
Vita's face to a pulp beat him today
don't like it all the hardware store deaths
they should have finished building this church
you have so much tetanus
oh
the Home Depot paint is real please don't
tell me there's a bunch of needles there must
be something it's gonna hurt to watch
oh man
oh
I don't even know what that is it's a lot
of weight it's a lot of stuff on a chain yeah
yeah oh
[Music] [Applause] climb him yes chunk by
chunk climb him like Everest
oh
just do one little shot to the Head yes exactly
that's exactly what I wanted exactly how I
wanted it to go how I imagined it at all yeah
no please don't kill her that's a death that
would get me mad at movie
right on time the other authorities I hope
his ex comes in with like a bridal outfit
they're in the right location and she's ordained
prison I'm like who's in prison [Music] why
are they all in prison what did I miss I guess
they did a lot of stuff in foreign soil they
get in prison for that [__] I mean law
order
you just did say if he doesn't get out of
there it's on him no law but maybe he just
helps that's right we forgot what the big
risk was the whole time prison
and he was so brave Tyler when it ended he
said to be brave like
that's how he saw you goodbye Tyler I wonder
if we got a cameo in this prison I feel a
cami don't you get a cameo sense coming like
a big big end of movie Cameo yeah I feel like
a cameo is kind of Ryan Reynolds it's always
Ryan Reynolds I suspect someone else
no it's ears yeah I told you not to get cool
[__] happens huh what if I could get you
out how does that work come and do another
job for us
no without my team I'm not leaving her behind
the whole team is here to survive members
my name doesn't matter no it does Mr Nobody
who I work for it was a naughty mother now
we got a franchise set up yeah we do first
one was a open-ended now this is a we got
a franchise
[Music] yeah sweet digs
oh Joe Russo wrote this one oh [__] all
right Story by Joan Anthony produced by John
Anthony Joe wrote it all right koi are you
going to the bathroom are we talking I got
this let's do it we're talking let's talk
I say we talk this is a really bright sweater
it is and it looks great I didn't realize
how bright it was I'm glad you noticed an
hour and 48 minutes in right now um yeah wow
what a what an experience I mean I feel like
this is one of those movies that's made for
reaction videos I am so tense and sore and
also emotionally sore and also I want to go
fight things all of them things I don't remember
the first one well enough to know if I like
it more than the first one I Remember Loving
the first one and I love this one but I don't
know I love more they're both coming from
a place of Love yeah yeah I feel like this
took it more in the direction that it probably
wanted to be I don't okay I yeah I don't I
just don't remember the details enough of
the first one I remember David Harbor surprised
me in the first one and Idris Elba surprised
me in this one well okay look it goes without
saying the action is just as phenomenal as
always and I my one concern was when we had
such an epic Runner that is this movie about
to get like boring oh sorry I defended the
casting for this too hey my one concern was
is this movie gonna get boring like you get
such a high from so early on in this movie
yeah and what is that like 20 minutes it's
like 20 it was 20 minutes long at least and
and then I'm like okay is any other action
set piece really good and then it does and
then the action manages to become something
that's more um they rely more on the emotional
engagement while still having that great choreography
and some cool do you care about all these
people enough that we were mad at that kid
like we were joking a lot but we understood
where he's coming from because of how good
the writing was exactly when you get to the
whole building sequence uh yeah you're on
the edge like okay one of our characters is
about to die it's one of those one of the
brothers and sisters yeah Nick or yes one
of them is gonna die right now I don't know
which one it's gonna be but one of them's
dead yeah uh so yeah like that had me on edge
and I think those sequences are great the
ending sequence is great Nick and Yaz were
so good in this one I I think it this one
might Edge out just because we were already
investing the characters we didn't have to
build them up so for me I I my instinct is
I like this one a little bit more but I need
to re-watch the first one but I do think instinctively
I think of Nick and Yaz as like so captivating
in this one like from the jump but I think
that's reliant on the first so I I don't know
how I barely remember them from the first
one at all at the beginning I thought that
and then once we ran I was like all right
I Remember Loving them but like it definitely
took me like the first two minutes to being
like right that did not happen for me okay
I was like guy I was like is that he's from
the I kept going he's from the first floor
yeah so but I found myself endeared to them
um so yeah the action's phenomenal I think
we've talked plain about it through I think
we've reviewed the action in the moment every
moment really need to review the action dude
it is epic and uh the like this is one of
those action movies that they ever released
it on the big screen I would love to like
why imagine if they they did IMAX conversion
so sometimes they play these at iPic it's
a it's like a gourmet restaurant movie theater
chain and you get the word on those and if
you find out you let me know because I want
to see this like that way I would love to
see this specific movie on the big switch
like as I love the John Wick action because
I what's the one thing about the wonder that
I have to ask myself is okay is it only one
of the best because it's a runner or does
the choreography of itself compete truly with
the job and that's what I mean the core office
has been incredible but I've seen like chapter
four of John Wick twice so I'm like okay it's
gonna be some somewhere between John Wick
how great is it 2023 I'm like are two of the
best action movies of all time like in like
really the same like two months apart with
some of the same stunties like some of the
same some people were in both well you see
I my same my same like little gripe that I
have with that I I remembered having with
the first one that I still think carries over
here is ah forgive me for being an [__]
what is the director's name Sam Margaret Sam
Margaret beautiful beer God damn it yeah yeah
I know I see his face and everything but us
Sam Hargrave like phenomenal action director
obviously no questions asked because even
when there's action here whenever there's
action it is it is emotionally engaging like
it is suspenseful it's more than just cool
it there's a there's a there's a attention
to it I am gripped by the heart in the moment
when it's happening I still do think the scenes
when there's not action need a little bit
of work on being a little more interested
like yeah the the opposite of this one I I
know you do I can tell that's our big difference
yeah because I'm I'm like anytime there's
a Slowdown I'm like okay not only do I need
this but also I love these people and then
like the the beautiful moment at the end like
I almost cried like I got emotions I was really
I was real close and it was hurt like because
like because they they didn't have her forgiveness
and I also like that like I I like that she
didn't forgive him like I also like that she
gave him the gift of forgive yourself I can't
forgive you I still went through this that's
unforgivable for me but I want you to live
your life without that yo dude I love that
I'm 100 on the same page as you the only my
little when I say a little grip I mean a little
grip because I it's so minor to the point
where I love the action and I only like this
song yeah like there's I don't love a lot
of the scenes when there's not action like
I'm I'm always I'm not bored I'm I'm interested
and I like the performers a lot I feel like
it's really elevated a lot by the performances
yeah I don't even I'm not even sure what it
really needs to be it's like because both
these movies have that thing where it's like
it's a very serious it's somber dramatic tone
and then like really cool action but the action
feels really supported because the scenes
leading into it are really serious so you
need that that way there's emotional heft
and a Thrust when there is the actions is
that why you're pulled into it for for the
character purposes like I totally get the
intention I don't even know exactly what my
wish is here for it I just know I'm not like
I'm not in love with it like whereas I can
say that for like I can be in love with scenes
like Mission Impossible movies when there's
no action or the John winter studies I could
be in love with those scenes and here I'm
like yeah this is about like by the numbers
as it is well executed you know so for me
John Wick one two and four I was invested
in the non-action scenes but I struggled with
three and then it got me back and forth yeah
whereas this one like obviously we're just
comparing because it's the same year but these
two very stylized action things I feel slightly
more emotional connection I think to extraction
I think the Chris Hemsworth character is more
relatable I also think he reminds me of what
like a modern day Martin Riggs would be and
I love the Lethal Weapon world like to me
he's like rigs but in like if he'd stayed
Special Forces and I think that's an archetype
I adore and I love John Wick but like there's
something about the the Tyler rake archetype
that I'm all in yeah I like the way this movie
decides to make an effort to even for its
follow-up to still keep it a character-driven
story within Tyler Rick because in that one
he's grieving and now he's finding a reason
to carry on yeah and the third one I'm finding
a resolution with his wife in some way I hope
he gets like a new reason to live in the next
one where you like that closure and I hope
the end of extraction becomes the three and
it goes like and then there's three they should
just flip the E I also doing
subtractions what is your fonts I don't care
about the movie but I also love that the two
brothers uh zarab and David are both played
by guys named tornike yeah well I think I
was also more endeared to the and the first
one I was more and dear to the whole like
again it's all true it's all action trucks
like the Father and Son uh dynamic in the
first one uh that's why I was like oh God
because they had the Cliffhanger remember
when he Dives in and goes up at the end and
then he sees like the Obscure Tyler in the
bed yeah like that I wanted to see what happened
there I did and we didn't get that but I like
the brothers here I like the villains yeah
I like the villains I do I think they're tied
like I I can't pick one because that has been
the four years whatever since I've seen it
well I think aesthetically it's cool too because
the first one is uh where's that the first
one I don't remember I don't know it's hot
and sweaty and icky yeah and here are just
like snowy landscape next time he's gotta
go to a jungle for predator three do you gotta
do the job oh just green Tyler rake doing
jungle stuff I think they use the environment
really well and I love how the Deep like the
cinematography if I remember that Sam Harker's
background was he a cinematographer before
I believe so I think he was also a stunt guy
I think he's got because like him and David
Leach are like these two epic stunties turned
if I remember correctly he's also his stunt
double he had a I remember he had a dick Hemsworth
he had a different profession prior to I think
he was Hemsworth was that that's how that
became friends just like David Leech was Brad
Pitt's I think we gotta this this Stunt Man
actor and director stunt coordinator yeah
I think he was the stunty for uh for Thor
in the beginning okay that's what it was he
wasn't a um yeah he wasn't a whatever not
a DP but yeah he was like a stunt coordinator
and then Avengers end game in Deadpool he
became the stunt coordinator from being a
stunt man yes okay and he's an absolute boss
uh I've never been a couple premieres and
he's always like so engaged in how people
move like it's cool to see him look at a room
because he's like tracking there's the axis
like he looks at a room in the in the way
the you know like when you watch someone how
like they turn left or right and then how
it tracks forward it's cool to watch people
that are stunned people like also navigate
like the distance between you and I yeah like
you can see him like coordinating and like
choreographing in a room like I love watching
stunt coordinators and the way his directing
is very much like z-axis based yeah because
that's how he sees love this director yeah
um but I really like this I think I like it
more than the first one um this is some of
the best action ever and I feel like the first
one's lost as big of a film as the first one
is I feel like it kind of got forgotten for
how great the action is in that movie I think
it was my top 10 in that year but I haven't
watched it since which is like you know that's
tricky yeah but the the action here I feel
like they really went up themselves because
the one or in the in the first one was amazing
and then this one because yeah obviously there's
cuts and [__] but sure the point is to
it's about the immersion experience which
it had we looked and we were still like
yeah
helicopter walk-offs chest lock off like how
did they do any there was a fire punching
sequence I think it's really great too because
Chris Hemsworth is like one of the only actors
to have become famous via the MCU and has
managed to find film a film work outside and
he's got this extraction franchise uh which
he excels in he's so happy fourth grade in
this role like yeah more than just the action
scenes like he really carries this performance
he might be the most successful of the core
I think so as out of the ones who became famous
through and then have managed to do stuff
outside of it yeah I think so because like
like a lot of people have carried on as they
were before the MCU he's elevated his career
so not to disparage Anyone But like everyone
else has stayed at a level he like used it
in a really wonderful way like he's got that
nice Middle Ground where yeah you know him
as Thor but you don't only want to see him
as Thor and I'll go see a Chris Hemsworth
movie I don't necessarily feel that way about
everyone yeah and we will not specify who
to be next just saying Chris Hemsworth I will
see his name also Joe and Anthony Russo I
will see their movies uh Sam Hargreaves I
will see like there are certain like things
that came out of the MCU that are live now
like diverging Paths of excitement yeah I
appreciate the extra effort that this franchise
gives specifically uh this movie too but they're
having some more of his like religious undertones
and having the whole for a movie about a grieving
father to be having this uh generational trauma
cultural trauma as well yeah to be [__]
into here I I respect the fact that they actually
make the concerted effort again it's more
like uh yeah I I don't I still don't quite
know what it what it is I could use a little
bit more zest to it or something a little
more unique in it because it kind of It kind
of just does play by the numbers for me it's
one of the things I find Charming about these
two films is they're like an 80s but I get
what I want I still feel like it could go
a little bit of the extra mile to enhance
the screen
ultimately I get what I want that's the thing
is like I don't want to harp on it too much
I'm just I'm harping on it only because I'm
like what am I looking for here uh because
yeah at the end of the day would I show up
for more than delivers in ways that are Beyond
satisfactory like I would give this movie
I would still meet you at four and a half
stars out of five I would still totally meet
you I think yeah I think we're both I think
I'm just saying it in an affirmative and you're
just saying looking for negative I'm just
saying look it's everything I want you're
like it's everything I want and that we're
on the same page it's just like the one thing
that we just up a little bit more it's just
what can we do with some of those uh
the Forgiveness that she gives him like I
feel like it's gonna have that you know what
it was that Idris Elba scene brought something
different for me um you know like having a
little bit more of that variation yeah like
Idris Elba I think brings a lot of that that
little spice to it oh immediately you know
and as soon as you see him on the porch you're
like this could be good because there is sort
of this like super soft like both these movies
have that let's just super somber series then
he's just so quick but to have a bit of that
variation allows the somberness to even have
more effect when you got a little bit more
variety in your scenes and I feel like Idris
Elba brings that variety again another very
tropey character but that that but throwing
that into the mix allows for uh more of an
emotional appeal for me so yeah I'm excited
for interceptible to be in here and to have
further enhancement great music great designs
overall um yeah this movie more than delivered
excellent action film bring on extraction
very pleased cannot wait so I didn't watch
the trailer Idris was a great surprise very
excited for attention so happy didn't watch
the trailer same so happy koi I gotta get
you out of here yep you got two minutes so
before we do I just really want to quickly
do a patron of the day shout out Andrew Hayes
if I ever needed someone to help me extract
someone from a prison it would be Andrew Hayes
because the guy's like five foot one and he's
stocky and bulky and he could be like beat
up people punch them in the knees and stuff
you can get him through vents go through crowds
crawl on through people's legs and that are
spread open if so if he has to rescue a child
he would be the perfect person to pull off
the ultimate Tyler straction experience so
Andrew my friend we gotta go out there we
gotta save some lives and by we I mean I show
up to your door and be like I'll split the
profits with you you get 30 I get 70 go in
there hand some business and thank you for
never pledging and never hitting us up on
patreon either don't know how much he thinks
5-1 is but that's not knees but I'm very confused
by his height scale five one will make it
easier duck in between players all right extract
are you five one I'm five eight and a half
five nights I'm a little bit offended there
under six footer we gotta defend our fellow
under six Footers
between seven foot five one I'm closer to
five one respect see you guys [Music]